that men on that man and this morning I
[Music]
had a bad day today I'm going to do my
best ok will do my best it's a little
raw I wish I had a couple days of
processed this but I will do my best
there is uh I mean it's it's a miracle
warrior tonight I think if we had kind
of called the show off everyone in the
room would have understood because we
lost a true Titan of pop culture today a
wonderful human being and for one of us
a good friend Adam West TVs Batman
passed away last night and he was 88
years old and he was my friend and I was
lucky to have met my childhood hero
about 20 years ago and that meeting led
to a long-lasting friendship that we had
up until his passing and it was one of
the real joys of my life to spend time
with him and to be his friend because
Adam West you have to understand for me
was other than my parents probably one
of the most influential grownups
for me growing up because from the age
of two on he was ever-present in my life
he taught me how to do right from wrong
and he was my hero and then as I got
older and wanted to get into performing
I started to grow up and appreciate his
work on that series how funny he was and
the bits that he were doing how subtle
his work was on that show and how funny
and talented he was as a performer so I
began to appreciate him on a whole
nother level but he was a constant in my
life he was always there and then as I
mentioned I met him in the late 1990s
and
at that time I was pretty much just a
fan and I think he appreciated the fact
that I was an enormous fan of his work
and the series and when I started
working on the radio I would often talk
about him and he and his manager
appreciated the fact that I would kept
his name alive in a town where a lot of
people had forgotten about Adam West he
was a guy who got kicked in the teeth by
show business he was he was on top of
the world when he was on the hottest
series on television in the 60s and when
that all went away nobody wanted to hire
the guy nobody wanted to talk about him
and I was a person who constantly talked
about him and sung his praises on the
radio and he and his manager always
appreciated that so that was the initial
beginning of our relationship but then
we got a chance to work together in the
early 2000s there was a network called
TV land it was doing a series of
mockumentaries about celebrities and
they asked me if I would be interested
in doing a show with Adam West where I
would play a fan who was obsessed with
Adam West and I said I'm just not that
good an actor I just and it was the
premise was that I was obsessed with
Adam West that I made a wager with him
that whatever he wanted to do any
sporting event that he would want to
battle me in if I won I would play can
put on the Batman cowl one last time and
we would take a picture together that
was the premise it was a flimsy premise
of a not very good show but it put me
and Adam together for the first time
ever working side-by-side and the show
was entirely improvised it was a
mockumentary kind of like a spinal tap
kind of thing where Adam and I was up to
us to kind of make up our own stuff and
for the first time ever we were peers we
were working together and for three days
we worked together side by side and I
got a brand new appreciation of this of
this man how much he loves the process
how much he loved working how much he
loved other performers and how he would
take other people under his wing and
help them and be so kind and so warm
and he was with me and those three days
changed our relationship we became
friends on a whole nother level because
we started to make
each other laughs and Adam loved to
laugh and he loved to make other people
laugh and that was the basis of all the
joy that he found in life was other
people's joy from his work if he met
fans of the Batman show or a family guy
that lit him up when he knew that he was
making someone feel better with what he
did this shell hasn't been on I don't
think since 2005 whatever this this
mockumentary that we did but I wanted to
show a little clip of him and I working
together and the premises it's a fishing
competition whoever catches the most
fish wins the bet and as I mentioned we
just shot for three days and we just
improvised together and this is where we
first started becoming fast friends so
here's a little clip from that show Adam
nice purse it's all men clothes worried
about that my daughter made death row
your daughter should be carrying him I'm
going to carry it always my dad's going
to be very focused and she's going to
keep it on the ball and really try to
beat Ralph
I don't think Ralph has any idea what
he's in for honestly let's check this
out Garmin no I still haven't caught one
neither of you I don't think you
understand the kind of pressure up here
trying to win the most important
challenge of my life how come the kids
got a fish and you don't well quit
showing off kid so by that point we were
both working on Family Guy and I would
see him almost on a weekly basis in the
at the studio as well as we recorded
those episodes and our friendship grew
and I got to meet his wife Marcel and
their kids and Nina his daughter you see
in that clip became a good friend of
mine and we started talking at one point
about the fact that her father didn't
have a star on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame and that was unacceptable to me and
it started me on a path that took four
or five years to finally get him
recognized on that walk because I
thought there's a lot of people who get
those awards who either have a movie
coming out that week or someone pays for
the studio's got a publicity machine
behind that but here's a guy that people
have known and appreciated for 50 years
and he deserved it and he kept telling
us he didn't really care but I knew that
he did and I knew more importantly fans
like me cared and would love to see him
be recognized and we we finally got it
we finally made it happen with the help
of his daughter and Seth MacFarlane of
course from Family Guy and I've got a
picture of one of the happiest days of
my life where I was able to share that
event with him he was so thrilled and
there's a ton of people who showed up
for that for that ceremony and he was so
thrilled to have them there and he was
thrilled that people appreciated his
work on Family Guy as much as they did
on Batman because he loved he loved
being current he didn't want to rest on
his laurels of something he did in the
60s he was always looking for whatever
new work he could get and I remember we
did a documentary called starring Adam
West about the process of getting him
that star and it was debuting at the San
Luis Obispo Film Festival up north and I
remember there was me and him and his
son-in-law James who had directed the
documentary and we went up there to
premiere it and I was going to do host a
Q&A with Adam after the screening so we
went up there and we had dinner before
this screening and we had we did the
screening to the Q&A went back to the
hotel and he and I sat at a table and we
had a couple glasses of wine and we just
talked all night long and Batman didn't
come up once we talked about our wives
and our kids and about our friends and
he was a really amazing man and it
dawned on me at that moment that my hero
of a child who was a hero because he was
a superhero had become my hero as an
adult because he was such a good man and
so kind and warm and forgiving I've
never seen a guy
with a better sense of humor about
himself and a better sense of sharing
and caring about other people it was
really an impressive guy and I made
myself a promise early on when I moved
to California that if I ever had a
chance if I ever if I ever won the
lottery and I was able to do his TV
series if I was going to write something
to produce something or direct something
that I was going to hire Adam West
because that would have been my way of
going full circle and thanking him for
everything that he had done is to put
him in something current so people could
see how talented he was again and I only
had that chance once with this guy when
we took Hollywood babble-on and we tried
to make a TV series out of it and we
went to AMC and they said make a pilot
and I said to Kevin the only thing I
really want to do for sure
is I want to get Adam on our show and we
came up with an idea for a sketch called
West on West where Adam West would do
dramatic readings of Kanye West's rap
lyrics and it was ridiculous and it was
silly and Adam [ __ ] loved the idea
because it was current it was happening
bound to with the video which is
happening in Seth Rogen and James Franco
had done their parody on the motorcycle
and it was very current and he loved the
idea of being in the middle of what was
happening instead of being talked about
as Batman from 50 years ago so we put it
together and we made it the closing
moment in our show and Kevin and I got a
chance to sit back and bring out Adam
West to tears of a studio audience and
have him do West on West and I think we
may have played it on the show before
but I don't care I thought I have a
final thank you I would like to show
what I think is sort of as cool as to
work here's Adam West West on West
[Music]
[Applause]
we have a special surprise my good
friend Adam West is releasing a new
spoken word album it's all dramatic
readings of Kanye West's lyrics
it's called West on West here to perform
Kanye West's bound to please welcome the
one true Batman
Oh
hey you remember but we first met okay
I don't remember and I know with the
hose I got the worst breath so hey maybe
we can make it to Christmas she asked me
what I wish for on the wish list have
you ever asked your [ __ ] brother bishop
maybe we could still make it to the
church steps but first you don't
remember how to forget after all these
long ass verses I'm tired you tired and
jesus wept
[Applause]
we had no money to spend on this pilot
and we couldn't pay Adam anything and he
said I don't care I'll come down and
just do it for you guys and he loved he
loves Kevin too and I don't want to make
it all about me because he did he loved
you I honestly I only got to meet Adam
because of Ralph and and of course
Ralph's got me by only a couple years
but I was this was my Batman this was
the person that taught me right from
wrong and that says a lot because I was
a Catholic school kid and the Bible
didn't teach me to want to be a good
person Batman did and that show was my
religion like you know we didn't have
cable TV we didn't have the Internet and
stuff like that you had like three
channels and then two syndicated
channels and every day after school when
I was a kid I would come home from 3
o'clock to four o'clock they'd run
back-to-back episodes of Batman and I
didn't I was I didn't know it was ironic
that's just the way heroes talked to me
like that never occurred to me it's
funny when I was a kid and then years
later when I was doing the fat man I'm
Batman podcast I got to have him on the
show and I got to tell him twice in
person what a giant he was for me the
guy who kind of set my morality
barometer but you honestly like beyond
you go beyond sand and sir like youth
you the man inspired you and you could
not pay your master back for all your
master done for you so what you did was
you reached into the heavens and you
literally pulled down a star for him
while he was here so many people you
know will trip over themselves when
somebody's gone but you did it while I
was here he got to be there got to see
him live forever on on Hollywood both of
our nut [ __ ] mattered to him he was a
creature of the industry he loved acting
he loved being out here and you
immortalized him
you weren't just a fan you were a giant
friend
[Applause]
and it is not my place to bestow this
but I think I think you're robbing the
heat beautiful picture we saw right
before we came out where we both kind of
we've been I crying on and off Ralph's
far more than than I because they were
tight friends and stuff he didn't just
lose the guy that like oh that's my
Batman who I met he was on a podcast
with me a couple times as you heard
these guys were tight but there's this
beautiful picture somebody put up on
Twitter which is you know Batman
climbing up the rope as he does the side
of the building but he's up in the
heavens yeah going to superhero heaven
with the rest of the Rogues everybody up
there gets to see everybody again I sure
hope so he was such a good friend to me
too and I don't want to make some
one-sided because here's a guy who was
my hero and an icon and all that good
stuff and he was always interested in me
and whenever I saw him he would say
Ralph
Howard Carey and Olivia my wife and my
daughter was always the first question
out of his mouth and when we did that
pilot weeks went by and he hadn't heard
anything and he sent me an email he said
Ralph what's going on with Hollywood
babble-on
and by then we had found out that AMC
had decided not to go forward with the
project and this guy was a gentleman by
the way Adam West the consummate
gentleman never heard a dirty word out
of his mouth I wrote him back and said
Adam thanks so much for doing what you
did meant the world to us sadly we're
not moving forward the project AMC has
passed and he wrote back with a
one-sentence response he said [ __ ] AMC
haha my favorite email I've ever done
from anyone
he was Batman to to a lot of people and
it would be remiss of us not to play a
little piece of him from that TV series
this is my own personal thanks are told
to me by the way with all this I
appreciate it been a hard day we did it
it did it almost there almost there this
is my personal favorite bit of business
he ever did because it was him on its
own reward does a little acting next to
him but not that much
it's a scene from a season two when Mr
Freeze is demanding that Bruce Wayne pay
the ransom for a noted scientist and
Batman has to deliver that ransom so
Commissioner Gordon and chief O'Hara
called Batman and Bruce Wayne on
separate phone lines to try to explain
to them the plan and Adam West with two
phones in each hand switch is his phone
hand back and forth and makes just the
slightest adjustment from Bruce Wayne's
voice to Batman's voice as the two of
them talk to each other it's kind of
[ __ ] remarkable and in 1966 I think
this [ __ ] passed by a lot of people they
didn't appreciate the subtle stuff that
this guy was doing on a on what at the
time was considered a silly campy show
but I think the fact that it lasted for
50 years of people still give a [ __ ]
proves that something else was going on
so here's a little taste of Adam West as
Bruce Wayne / Batman Commissioner Gordon
is on the other phone with Batman mr.
Wayne and perhaps if we put the two
phones together you could talk to him
yourself
alright chief I don't have much time
Batman yes mr. Wayne
have you heard mr. Freeze's scurrilous
demands just briefly if Robin and I
hacked his go-betweens are you prepared
to make the telecast at midnight and pay
the ransom mr. Wayne I have no choice
Batman then may I suggest you tape the
broadcast from the Commissioner's Office
an hour earlier and we will have a dummy
package of money a dummy package of
money that sons risky risk is our
business mr. Wayne and I have the same
faith in you that all of Gotham City has
I hope Robin and I are deserving of that
faith I'll make the necessary
arrangements and meet you with the
Commissioner's Office at 11:00
fine did you call that commissioner
indeed I did Batman will you set up the
tape telecast and have the dummy package
of money waiting see you at 11:00
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
wouldn't mind joining me just if you got
a drink raise it up
rest in peace bright night cheers Adam
thank you choose
[Music]
[Applause]